Bolivia está viviendo semanas de intriga,
miedo e incertidumbre.
El país se enfrenta a una situación política
y económica límite.
La pregunta es…
¿Puede Bolivia quebrar?
¿Qué está sucediendo en este país andino
tras el triunfal regreso al poder del MAS,
el Movimiento al Socialismo de Evo Morales?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo os
vamos a dar todas las respuestas.
¡Arranquemos!
Os hago una pregunta: ¿Qué tienen en común
Lenin Moreno, Alberto Fernández y, ahora
también, Luis Arce?
3, 2,1…
¡Exacto!
Los son herederos de los grandes líderes
del conocido como socialismo del siglo XXI…
Pero, ¿sabéis qué?
Tienen algo más en común: los tres salieron
“ranas”.
Es decir, que no se conformaron con la condición
de ser líderes sumisos de sus grandes padrinos
políticos.
Lenin Moreno se enfrentó a Rafael Correa,
Alberto Fernández ha terminado fatal con
todo el Kirchnerismo y Luis Arce.
Bueno, digamos, que ahora la lucha de Evo
Morales por regresar al poder le ha hecho
chocar de frente con su “delfín”, que
por supuesto, no está dispuesto a devolverle
el sillón de mando.
¿El resultado?
A la inquietante crisis económica a la que
se está empezando a enfrentar Bolivia tenemos
que sumar también una feroz guerra política
entre el gobierno y la oposición, y entre
los propios miembros del partido de gobierno.
Hablamos de un enorme caos…
que está poniendo contra las cuerdas el futuro
del país.
Estas, queridos, amigos, amigas, son las 3
grandes crisis que amenazan con tumbar Bolivia.
Atentos.
T1(EL MOVIMIENTO EN FALSO DE EVO MORALES)
Hasta la fecha, Evo Morales ha sido el presidente
constitucional que más tiempo ha permanecido
en el poder en Bolivia de forma continuada.
Morales tuvo las riendas del país entre los
años 2006 y 2019.
Y no solo eso.
Su propia figura se ha convertido en el icono
de la política boliviana.
Claro que…
No todo dura para siempre.
Evo Morales hizo todo lo posible para poder
presentarse a las elecciones de 2019.
Que era algo que en principio la Constitución
no le permitía.
Ya os lo contamos en VisualPolitik.
Pero Evo quería presentarse, así que en
2016 impulsó un referéndum para poder postularse
a un tercer mandato…
Un referéndum que perdió.
Pero eso no le iba a detener.
En 2017 su partido, el MÁS presentó un recurso
ante el Tribunal Constitucional denunciando
que la limitación de mandatos violaba sus
derechos humanos…
(((Gesto de incomprensión)))...
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
¡Sorpresa!
El mismo Tribunal que tiene la misión de
hacer cumplir la Constitución…
Decidió saltársela haciendo caso omiso de
un precepto muy claro…
Y así autorizó a Evo Morales a ser candidato.
Claro que la cosa terminó como el rosario
de la aurora.
Las elecciones de 2019 fueron un desastre.
¿Qué por qué?
Pues…
Fijaos.
C1(“Las manipulaciones e irregularidades
señaladas no permiten tener certeza sobre
el margen de victoria del candidato Morales
sobre el candidato Mesa.
Por el contrario, a partir de la abrumadora
evidencia encontrada, lo que sí es posible
afirmar es que ha habido una serie de operaciones
dolosas encaminadas a alterar la voluntad
expresada en las urnas.”
Análisis sobre las elecciones generales de
Bolivia de la Organización de Estados Americanos.)
C2(“La Misión de Expertos Electorales de
la UE pudo comprobar que varias actas deberían
haber sido anuladas: casos donde se agregó
votos al MAS”.
Informe de la Misión de Observadores Electorales
de la Unión Europea)
Queridos amigos, amigas, las elecciones de
2019 estuvieron repletas de irregularidades.
Y ya lo veis, tanto la OEA como la Unión
Europea fueron contundentes: había indicios
muy claros de pucherazo.
Tantos que el propio Evo Morales se comprometió
a repetirlas…
Pero no fue suficiente.
El 10 de noviembre de ese mismo 2019, en medio
de enormes protestas, el mandatario se vio
obligado a dimitir.
Se trasladó a México pidiendo el asilo político
y denunció un golpe político-policial en
su contra.
(A: yo dije en una reunión, yo nunca hoy
a renunciar, quiero que sepan mis hermanas
y hermanos estoy renunciando para que Mesa
y Camacho no sigan quemando las casas de mis
hermanos, por eso hemos decidido renunciar
a nuestros cargos.)
(…)
(B: Ahora me he convencido como algunos técnicos
de la OEA están al servicio, no de las familias
humildes, sino de grupos de poder.
Entendí perfectamente.)
(Tras las elecciones de 2019 y las denuncias
de fraude se produjeron enormes protestas
y manifestaciones.
La tensión y la violencia no paraban de crecer.
Los manifestantes, incluso asaltaron la propia
casa de Evo Morales en Cochabamba.
Finalmente, el 12 de noviembre, la entonces
segunda vicepresidenta de la cámara de senadores,
Jeanine Añez fue proclamada presidenta del
Estado Plurinacional de Bolivia.)
Añez ratificó la convocatoria de elecciones…
Pero la pandemia de la COVID-19 obligó a
retrasar todo el calendario electoral.
Al final los comicios no se celebraron hasta
el 18 de octubre del 2020.
Fue una carrera en la que oposición al MÁS
pecó de exceso de confianza.
Llegó fragmentada con dos candidaturas diferentes:
la del expresidente Carlos Mesa, por un lado,
y la de Luis Camacho, el líder político
de la provincia de Santa Cruz, por otro.
En frente tuvieron al MÁS con un nuevo candidato:
N1(Evo Morales anunció que Luis Arce será
el candidato a presidente del MAS en las nuevas
elecciones de Bolivia (19 de enero de 2020).
InfoBae)
Y ya os podéis imaginar lo que pasó: con
el 55,11% de los votos, Luis Arce, “Lucho”,
el exministro de finanzas de Morales ganó
las elecciones.
Y no solo eso, también se hizo con el control
legislativo.
21 de los 26 escaños del Senado y 75 de los
130 asientos del Congreso quedaron bajo el
control del MAS.
La oposición fracasó a lo grande.
Sin embargo, la victoria no iba a suponer
para el MÁS la tranquilidad que muchos auguraban.
La lucha entre el expresidente y el nuevo
presidente estaba servida.
¡Atentos!
T2(¿DELFÍN O TIBURÓN?)
Luis Arce fue algo así como el gestor en
la sombra de la economía boliviana durante
la presidencia de Evo morales.
Bajo el liderazgo absoluto del expresidente,
Arce encontró cierto margen de maniobra.
Y es que lo cierto es que las cosas empezaron
con buen pie.
Fijaos.
N2(22 de diciembre del 2005: En una decisión
"histórica", el FMI le perdonó la deuda
a Bolivia.
El Fondo Monetario Internacional (FMI) anunció
ayer que el primero de enero de 2006 condonará
la deuda de 19 países, incluidos Nicaragua,
Bolivia y Honduras.
InfoBae)
Fue un regalo equivalente a casi el 3% del
PIB boliviano.
Pues bien, apenas unos días después de este
“regalo”, Evo Morales nombró a Luis Arce
como Ministro de Hacienda.
Y tres años después le puso al frente del
superministerio de Economía y Finanzas.
Arce cada vez tenía más peso y más poder.
Durante su primera etapa como Ministro se
centró en renegociar los contratos de exploración
y explotación de commodities, como el gas
natural, los metales y los derivados agrícolas.
¿Y sabéis qué?
Las cosas siguieron saliendo a las mil maravillas.
Los precios de las commodities se dispararon
a nivel internacional, lo que provocó un
contexto inmejorable para la economía boliviana.
El dinero estaba empezando a entrar en las
arcas públicas como nunca antes.
Fueron los años dorados de la minería boliviana.
De repente entró tanto dinero en el país
que el saldo por cuenta corriente pasó del
estar en negativo a llegar a registrar dos
dígitos positivo.
Además, a diferencia de países como Venezuela,
Bolivia fue mucho más prudente con el gasto
público.
Así que la deuda externa se desplomó y el
gobierno tenía ingentes recursos para gastar
en todo tipo de proyectos.
La narrativa del gobierno de Evo Morales era
muy clara: gracias al socialismo antiimperialista
del MAS Bolivia volvía a ser una nación
libre, soberana y próspera.
[Qué luego el origen de toda esa prosperidad
fuera la venta de recursos naturales al bloque
hegemonía e imperialista occidental…
Bueno, eso ya es otra historia.]
Sea como sea, la cuestión es que las cosas
mejoraron.
Y ahora es cuándo muchos os preguntaréis…
¿Por qué demonios en VisualPolitik nos están
hablando de presuntos logros del gobierno
de Morales?
¿Es que acaso VisualPolitik está siendo
financiado por la industria cocalera de Bolivia?
Pues…
Evidentemente no.
Lo importante aquí es que tras este contexto
económico que nutrió la enorme popularidad
de Evo Morales estaba un arquitecto político
con nombre y apellidos.
Una identidad que poco a poco empezó a resonar
en la opinión pública: estamos hablando,
por supuesto, de Luis Arce.
N3(10 de octubre de 2014: El hombre detrás
del éxito de Evo Morales.
Arce concibió políticas para el sector gasífero
que generaron grandes ingresos al tiempo que
controló el gasto.
A partir de mayo de 2006, el gobierno exigió
que las empresas energéticas extranjeras
pagaran 32% adicional en impuestos y regalías.
WSJ)
C3(Marx dice: para lograr el salto al socialismo
hay que desarrollar las fuerzas productivas.
Es lo que estamos haciendo".
Luis Arce en 2014)
Su imagen cada vez era más reconocida.
Sin embargo, en 2017 tuvo que renunciar a
su ministerio por un cáncer de riñón.
Su estado de salud se complicó y al final
tuvo que ser tratado en Brasil.
En 2019, no obstante, retornó al ministerio…
Aunque duró muy poco en el cargo…
Tuvo que salir del gobierno junto a Morales
tras la denuncia de pucherazo.
Sin embargo, cuando su nombre apareció para
hacerse con la candidatura del MAS el acierto
de Evo Morales parecía muy claro.
Arce no solo tenía una buenísima valoración
general sino que además no infundí a miedo
entre los empresarios del país.
Además, se presentaba como todo un experto
económico en mitad del torbellino que suponía
la pandemia.
Y por supuesto…
Ganó.
El problema para Evo Morales es que desde
el primer momento el candidato que era conocido
como “el delfín” pasó a convertirse
en una especie de depredador con agenda propia.
C4("Evo no tendrá ningún papel en nuestro
Gobierno".
"Tendremos que aplicar medidas de austeridad.
No hay otra opción si no tenemos suficientes
ingresos para cubrir nuestros gastos actuales"
Luis Arce, virtual presidente de Bolivia")
N4(10 de noviembre del 2020: Luis Arce nombra
un gabinete distanciado de Evo Morales.
France24)
Por supuesto, queridos amigos, amigas, eso
de pretender dejar al antiguo líder en el
banquillo no le iba a salir gratis al nuevo
presidente.
Justo aquí fue cuando se puso en marcha una
lucha fratricida a cara de perro dentro del
MAS.
Una lucha que poco a poco se ha ido recrudeciendo
y que hoy ya es casi tan pública como la
ruptura entra Shakira y Piqué.
N5(8 de septiembre de 2022: Evo Morales acusa
a ministros de Bolivia de ejecutar "un plan
negro" contra él.
El líder del MAS ha aseverado que miembros
del Gobierno han contratado a "guerreros digitales"
para "atacarlo" a través de las redes sociales.
La Nación)
C5("Nosotros somos bomberos y el Lucho (Arce)
no reconoce, la ministra de Presidencia no
reconoce, cómo hacemos esfuerzo para que
no haya conflictos y ellos [los ministros]
buscan conflictos" Evo Morales)
Cuando Evo Morales colocó a Luis Arce lo
hizo pensando en su propio regreso al poder…
Y eso es exactamente lo que persigue.
En las elecciones de 2025 Evo Morales quiere
hacerse de nuevo con los mandos del país.
Sin embargo, hay un problema, Luis Arce también
aspira a ser reelegido.
Se vende como el cambio regeneracional a la
etapa ya caduca del MAS de Morales.
Así que ya lo veis, el conflicto está servido…
Y todo apunta a que las cosas dentro del MAS
se irán poniendo cada vez más y más tensas
a media que se acerquen las elecciones.
Claro que esta no es la única crisis política
que vive el país.
Atentos.
T3(EL CENSO Y SU MES DE FURIA)
Recordemos que en noviembre de 2019, las protestas
contra Molares fueron tan grandes que no sé
salvo ni su casa.
Por supuesto, todo ese descontento de gran
parte de la sociedad boliviana no desapareció,
solo se recluyó.
La sociedad boliviana sigue estando fuertemente
fragmentada…
Lo que resulta en todo un polvorín.
La chispa que encendería la mecha llegó
de forma inesperada y un tanto curiosa: mediante
censo poblacional en el departamento de Santa
Cruz, el feudo de la oposición.
Fijaos.
(En octubre de 2022, el gobierno boliviano
retrasó la realización del censo de población
y vivienda hasta 2024, alegando limitaciones
por el tema covid-19.
Bolivia es un país unitario con autonomías,
es decir, los impuestos se centralizan y posteriormente
se distribuyen según la población que tiene
cada departamento.
De igual forma, la distribución de representantes
en la Cámara de diputados está sujeta al
censo, y si este se realiza este año tal
y como corresponde, los resultados podrían
aplicarse ya en las elecciones de 2025.
​​
Las tendencias demográficas de Santa Cruz
la posicionan como la jurisdicción que más
atrae a la migración interna, por lo que
es de esperar que la distribución poblacional
haya cambiado considerablemente.
Se espera que esta jurisdicción consiga más
diputados y nuevas circunscripciones donde
el voto urbano gane terreno frente al voto
rural.
Y, claro, siendo Santa Cruz el gran bastión
opositor, el retraso del censo fue algo así
como una jugarreta para favorecer el MAS en
las elecciones de 2025.)
Como respuesta se convocó en esta región
un paro total, el cual duró 36 días en un
contexto de fuertes protestas que se saldaron
con 4 fallecidos y casi 200 heridos.
Por supuesto, la paralización del motor productivo
del país por más de un mes provocó perdidas
multimillonarias para la actividad económica:
N6(Paro en Santa Cruz: 35.000 bolivianos habrían
perdido su empleo, según la Confederación
Nacional de Micro y Pequeña Empresa de Bolivia.
El Ministerio de Economía y Finanzas Públicas
calculó un daño económico mayor a los US$780
millones por el paro cívico en Santa Cruz.
Bloomberg)
Finalmente, la Cámara de Diputados tuvo que
aprobar una ley sobre el empadronamiento cumpliendo
las exigencias de Santa Cruz.
(Claro que ahí no quedó todo.
En medio de las protestas, el gobernador de
Santa Cruz, Luis Camacho, si, el mismo que
se presentó en las elecciones de 2020, fue
detenido bajo todo tipo de acusaciones: racismo,
discriminación, atentados contra la libertad
de trabajo, atentados contra la seguridad
de los servicios públicos y desórdenes o
perturbaciones públicas.
Así que sí, el censo tendrá lugar, pero
la oposición sigue sin dormir tranquila.)
Esta es, queridos amigos, amigas, la segunda
gran crisis a la que se enfrenta Bolivia.
Pero aún nos queda la tercera…
La crisis económica.
¿Puede llegar a quebrar Bolivia?
Atentos.
T4(TODOS CONTRA TODOS)
Si bien durante su época como Ministro, Arce
logró mantener los incrementos del gasto
público limitados a los crecientes ingresos
fiscales, ahora en su rol como presidente
ha tenido que enfrentar un clima mucho más
adverso.
Si entre 2006 y 2014 Bolivia se benefició
de los precios al alza de las materias primas,
a partir de entonces la cosa se dio la vuelta
y el país comenzó a experimentar grandes
déficits por cuenta corriente.
Es decir, que las importaciones superaban
por mucho a las exportaciones.
Poco a poco esto fue vaciando la caja de divisas
extranjeras del Banco Central.
Para que os hagáis una idea, entre 2014 las
reservas extranjeras de Bolivia se han desplomado
más de un 75%.
A finales del I Trimestre del 2023, el banco
central apenas tenía en reservas razonablemente
líquidas unos 900 millones de dólares.
Una cantidad totalmente insuficiente para
garantizar los pagos al exterior de Bolivia.
La situación es desesperada…
El gobierno ha tenido que restringir la compra
de dólares.
Y el miedo a que esto deje de ser posible
en cualquier momento hizo que se formaran
larguísimas colas en las entidades bancarias.
Pero ese no es el único problema.
Para colmo, el gobierno también ha estado
sufriendo desde el año 2014 grandes déficits
públicos.
¿El resultado?
N7(Fitch rebaja calificación de Bolivia a
'B-'; perspectiva negativa.
Fitch)
Ahora el gobierno está intentando encontrar
nuevas formas de financiación…
Y ha puesto su mirada en los fondos de pensiones.
No es algo nuevo, sino un paso más.
Tal y como ya os contamos en Latampolitik
para Patreon, desde hace más de un año el
gobierno ha estado emitiendo bonos soberanos
a 20, 30 y 50 años.
Bonos que se los ha estado colocando a los
fondos de pensiones, de tal forma que aproximadamente
un tercio de los 24.000 millones de dólares
de ahorro en pensiones depende ya de la deuda
pública.
Pues bien, en abril de 2023 se decretó la
estatización de todos los fondos.
Es decir, que el estado les va a colocar mucha
más deuda pública.
A finales de abril el gobierno también tuvo
intervenir el Banco Fassil.
Es decir, que la cosa no pinta bien…
Al menos en el corto plazo.
El
precio de las materias primas se está incrementando,
lo que podría traducirse en más ingresos
fiscales y más entrada de divisas a medio
plazo.
El gobierno también está reduciendo ayudas
como el subsidio de combustibles, está cambiando
la ley para poder monetizar los 2.500 millones
de dólares en reservas de oro que hoy no
se pueden tocar y mientras tanto confía en
que la llegada de créditos internacionales
en dólares sea suficiente para capear el
temporal.
Veremos si todo este plan da resultado.
La cuestión es que Evo Morales está aprovechando
el momento para lanzarse a la yugular del
gobierno.
Por ejemplo, el pasado 26 de marzo el MAS
cumplió 28 años.
La fecha era clave para buscar una cierta
reconciliación, pero nada más lejos de la
realidad.
Evo Morales cargó contra Arce delante del
propio presidente y frente a las bases del
partido.
Fijaos.
(Hermano Lucho, presidente, tiene que mejorar
su gabinete para hacer una buena gestión
política (…) es importante que no haya
inflación, que no haya déficit, ¿pero sin
expansión económica?)
La ruptura dentro del MAS es prácticamente
un hecho, el 2022 terminó con el principal
centro industrial del país afectado por un
largo paro y vuelto contra el gobierno, la
tensión con la oposición no deja de crecer,
el recorte de subsidios y la captura de los
fondos de pensiones está caldeando el ambiente
social y para colmo la crisis de divisas puede
terminar traduciéndose en nuevos problemas.
La paz es lo que menos probable parece en
el futuro de Bolivia.
Estas que hemos visto son las 3 grandes crisis
a las que se enfrenta este país.
La pregunta ahora es: ¿Lograrán superar
esta crisis de divisas?
¿Pondrá el gobierno en orden las cuentas
públicas?
¿Qué ocurrirá en 2025?
¿Se romperá el MAS?
¿Presentarán Morales y Arce candidaturas
separadas?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
Visualpolitik si es que aún no lo habéis
hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.